nos encontramos en el centro histórico
de ciudad de guatemala donde hay
múltiples cánticos uno de ellos es el de
va a caer va a caer la dictadura va a
caer se habla de que el gobierno
alejandro giammatei ha cometido
múltiples actos de corrupción como
fraude electoral otorgar a dedo
diferentes y multimillonarios contratos
a los sectores de infraestructura y de
petróleo y de tejer una red de
corrupción con las más altas
instituciones del gobierno justamente
para blindarse de cualquier
investigación vamos a preguntar
justamente a los manifestantes porque se
encuentran acá y si el presidente
alejandro giammatei debería renunciar
señora disculpe porque está usted
manifestándose hoy
para que renuncie el presidente no
queremos delincuentes queremos un pueblo
trabajador
guatemala es un país de 18 millones de
habitantes en donde el 60% de su
población vive en la pobreza y es este
gobierno el de allá mate y el que ha
bloqueado incluso el aumento del salario
mínimo pareciera un país en el cual es
insostenible que la gente pueda seguir
viviendo con sus salarios porque se
encuentran manifestando hoy y cree usted
que el presidente debería renunciar
estamos manifestando principalmente por
la toma injustificada del rector actual
de la universidad de san carlos porque
no siguió el proceso adecuado y tomó el
cargo sin haberlo ganado sin haber hecho
las elecciones adecuadamente y sin
cumplir los requisitos entonces pedimos
principalmente su renuncia y de todo lo
que lo están apoyando incluyendo al
presidente
esta es una manifestación que involucra
a diferentes sectores de la sociedad
civil estudiantes profesores
trabajadores una manifestación que corre
un riesgo porque actualmente en el
congreso cursa la iniciativa 60 79 en la
cual el propio gobierno podría utilizar
el uso de la fuerza de policía y
militares para reprimir estas
manifestaciones